[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
gestern hatte ich die ehre mit unserer
kolleginnen allianz ingo zu sprechen
alina jan schenk ist abgeordnete des
ukrainischen parlaments
sie begann unser telefonat mit den
worten heute lebe ich noch ich weiß
nicht was morgen ist
heute lebe ich noch ich weiß nicht was
morgen ist das ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die bittere realität für
millionen von menschen in der ukraine
in einer mischung aus wut enttäuschung
stärke trauer und entschlossenheit
schilderte mir alina jan schenk die
kriegsverbrechen putins und der
russischen soldaten
sie schilderte mir die phosphorbomben
und die streumunition
sie schilderte mir das schicksal der
vielen getöteten zivilisten und
zivilisten in mario kohle und kharkiv
unter ihnen auch kinder
kinder die von putins bomben getötet
werden
und kinder die verhungern und verdursten
verhungern und verdursten weil keine
humanitäre hilfe in die stadt gelassen
wird während gleichzeitig russische
streitkräfte die wenigen flugkorridore
ins visier nehmen
mir schnitt ist das herz zu wenn ich
diese berichte höre
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen auch am 21 tag des krieges
müssen wir alles verantwortbare tun um
uns diesem terror entgegenzustellen und
jeden tag
und jeden tag aufs neue prüfen was
möglich ist auch am jahrestag des
gefälschten krim referendums der heute
ist müssen wir feststellen dass unsere
starken internationalen bemühungen noch
nicht gereicht haben und putins
angriffskrieg zu stoppen und ich will
damit überhaupt nicht die bemühungen und
entscheidungen auf deutscher und
europäischer ebene schmälern im
gegenteil es war wichtig und notwendig
die präsident losen sanktionen zu
beschließen und waffen und ausrüstungen
zu liefern und ich bin der
bundesregierung sehr dankbar dafür
wir müssen aber auch feststellen dass
wir aufgrund einer verfehlten
energiepolitik in einer fossilen
abhängigkeit stecken die unseren
handlungsspielraum einschränken und es
ist für niemanden ein geheimnis dass wir
grünen seit langer zeit für die
erkenntnis streiten das energiewende und
klimaschutz auch sicherheitspolitische
fragen beantworten und deshalb ist es
jetzt so überfällig dass wir wie robert
habeck es gesagt hat täglich
unabhängiger von öl kohle und gas in
deutschland werden
die russischen deviseneinnahmen aus
fossilen energieimporten haben diesen
krieg mitfinanziert und darum irritiert
mich so manche aktuelle debatte die wir
führen und ich erwarte dass in einem
solchen moment in dem ein diktator ein
europäisches nachbarland überfällt sich
auch ministerpräsidenten hinter die
bundesregierung und nicht vorzustellen
oder wenigsten konstruktiv an lösungen
mitarbeiten
denn natürlich natürlich müssen wir
jenseits markiger überschriften für eine
sozial gerechte entlastung sorgen und es
muss uns doch darum gehen dass wir diese
entlastung zu den menschen bringen die
sie brauchen und damit nicht die
gewinnmargen von ölkonzernen steigern
und damit letztendlich dafür sorgen dass
putin auch noch unbeabsichtigt davon
profitiert
und die entwicklung der der spritpreise
bei sinkenden ölpreisen im moment ist
zusicherung eines freien markt ist dass
man am rande ein fall für das kartellamt
und das muss der hauptfokus dabei sein
aber liebe liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wo im moment vor allem gelder
und unsere aufmerksamkeit gebraucht
werden das haben wir im gemeinsamen
beschluss der sondersitzung hier
formuliert in diesem raum für die
politische wirtschaftliche finanzielle
humanitäre und militärische
unterstützung der ukraine und um ganz
konkretes angebot dabei zu machen oder
ein beispiel zu nennen beispielsweise
bei der evakuierung aufnahme und pflege
der noch lebenden holocaust überlebenden
aus der ukraine hier können wir putins
lüge der die nazi fixierung die
angeblich machen wir ganz konkret
entlarven denn er bombardiert ja nicht
nur die gedenkstätten der deutschen
verbrechen sondern setzt die
überlebenden der shoah des deutschen
nazi terrors neuen qualen und traumata
im land aus
meine damen und herren
alina gab mir noch eine botschaft mit
lose your 4 verliert eure angst wir
sollten aufhören angst vor putin zu
haben angst ist seine mafia methode er
will gefürchtet werden damit er selbst
nichts zu fürchten hat und ich will
ängste nicht kleinreden und natürlich
bedarf es kluge und rationale abwägung
unseres handelns und deshalb müssen wir
jeden tag prüfen ob unser handeln
einerseits angemessen und ausreichend
aber andererseits auch in alle
richtungen verantwortbar ist aber diese
zeitenwende darf keine epoche unserer
angst sein denn wo vor putin selber
angst hat das ist die idee von
demokratie und freiheit die idee der in
seinem eigenen land unterdrückt und
gegen die idee gegen die in der ukraine
in den krieg zieht alina jan schenk
erzählte mir vom unbedingten willen
ihrer mitmenschen sich diesem russischen
terror entgegenzustellen und wir sind
uns mit alina und unseren ukrainischen
freundin und freunden einig den
europäischen geist der freiheit der
demokratie und des rechts wird putin nie
besiegen können vielen dank
so war die erste frau die erste regus
hier in der aktuellen situation lage in
der ukraine und wir sehen auch dass die
regierung
ungewöhnlich gefüllt ist der
landwirtschaftsminister bundeskanzler
olaf scholz haben wir eben gesehen die
außenministerin bundesfinanzminister
der
bundesfinanzminister christian linder
innenministeriums justizminister also
hier viele mitglieder der regierung der
dieser aktuellen stunde folgen johann
wadephul jetzt für die unionsfraktion
ihr leben nach wie vor einem
völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine
die russischen truppen legen das land in
schutt und asche
führen einen brutalen kampf auch gegen
die zivilbevölkerung
insbesondere frauen kinder und alte
leiden darunter besonders
eine humanitäre katastrophe vor unseren
augen
es werden sollten da truppen eingesetzt
die keine richtigen kombattanten sind
kriegsvölkerrecht wird zudem
verletzt diejenigen die dort sind
berichten von der hölle auf erden und
deswegen stellt sich in der tat die
frage
die grundaussage kollege wagener teile
ich wo steht deutschland in dieser
situation muss deutschland an der seite
des freien demokratischen souveränen
ukraine stehen da ist unser platz und
irgendwo anders
und später aber dann doch kraftvoller
die bundesregierung reagiert wie haben
manche diskussionen auch vor der
bundeskanzler ihrer regierungserklärung
hier geführt die
dann in der tat wie sie gesagt haben
eine zeitenwende eingeleitet hat nach
ihrer auffassung aber die frage stellt
sich jetzt
haben wir das verstanden und machen wir
in dem sinne politik als europäer das
nato-mitglied als wohnung zurück
deutschland und auch als deutscher
bundestag und ich muß ich möchte mit der
formalie beginnen morgen spricht
präsident selensky wahrscheinlich in
diesem haus
würde mich freuen wenn das technisch
gelingt und wenn es ihm möglich ist
körperlich wird eine ehre für uns alle
sein aber dass wir danach nach ihrem
willen dann eine diskussion über die
impfpflicht führen während heute beide
häuser des us-kongresses
zusammen gesessen haben und dann auch
dem präsidenten zugehört und darüber
debattiert haben während das
australische parlament dem fahrer den
präsidenten zuhört und dann auch
debattiert ich liebe das wort nicht aber
ich empfinde fremdscham für die mehrheit
was die ampel hier macht dass wir nicht
morgen im anschluss sofort eine debatte
zur situation in der ukraine
führen
das wissen sie ganz genau auch wenn sie
erfreulicherweise jetzt anwesend sind
seitens der regierung auch der
bundeskanzler selber
dass das morgen die richtige zeit
gewesen wäre übrigens auch in erfüllung
ihrer parlamentarischen verpflichtungen
und berichtspflicht das bundesregierung
in der letzten wahlperiode braucht die
bundeskanzlerin auf der karte nur mal in
die nähe von brüssel zu kommen und dann
hat der busch man schon als pdf der fdp
verlangt dass sich eine
regierungserklärung gibt wo bleibt ihre
bereitschaft gegenüber dem parlament
rechenschaft abzulegen das erwarten wir
von ihnen
das recht wo
andere zeigen dass sie dazu in der lage
sind und war genau sie haben gesagt wir
müssen jetzt alles tun wer ist es denn
der nicht bereit ist über weitere
sanktionen zu reden wir haben gesagt
nord stream 1 kommt auf die kommt in die
diskussion wer legt es dann aber wagener
ist auch ihr grüner wirtschaftsminister
der das ausschließt dann machen sie doch
mehr dann machen sie doch mehr und
ehrlich gesagt bei den waffenlieferungen
ist ein schwerer schritt für sie gewesen
die erkennen dass anja gut nein das muss
man in der tat sagen das ist ihm schwer
gefallen sie haben das spät gemacht sind
auch noch nicht alle angekommen
offensichtlich es gibt den dringenden
wunsch der ukraine das meer geliefert
wird und wenn und wenn frau künast wenn
die waffenlieferungen die ihn bisher
erfolgt sind nicht nur reine
gewissensberuhigung für sie gewesen sein
sollen sondern wenn sie ernsthaft einen
beitrag zur verteidigungsfähigkeit
dieser freien ukraine leisten wollten
und weiter wollen darauf kommt es an
dann müssen sie jetzt auch zu weiteren
waffenlieferungen bereit sein wir
liefern weniger als dänemark und ich bin
ein freund dänemark das ist doch auch
wieder eine sache wo man sich schämen
muss dass wir nicht zu mehr in der lage
sind und der bundeskanzler in der rede
haben sie gesagt wir brauchen eine
stärkere bundes wären wir stellen ein
100 milliarden euro in ein
sondervermögen
bereit um die bundeswehr zu stärken und
es ist von ihnen und vom finanzminister
an die union appelliert worden dass wir
das unterstützen sollen wozu das hat
friedrich merz gesagt wir dem grunde
nach berechtigt sind ruhig muss auch
hier mal daran erinnert ja frau kollegin
hat man das will ich ihnen klar sagen
und das habe ich auch schon an dem
sonntag gesagt dass wir hier einen
blankoscheck ausstellen und nur die
verfassungsrechtliche ermöglichung der
aufnahme weiterer schulden in dieser
großen höhe machen das werden sie nicht
erleben wir erwarten dass wir an der
abfassung des gesetzestextes dass wir in
der abfassung der grundgesetzänderung
und an der verwendung dieser mittel
übrigens nur für die bundeswehr dass wir
an daran beteiligt werden das mögen sie
gewährleisten und wenn das gewährleistet
ist werden wir zustimmen aber eine
beteiligung daran
eine beteiligung daran und das wäre gute
gute parlamentarische city gewesen eine
beteiligung der unionsfraktion daran hat
es nicht gegeben und wer mit uns
gemeinsam die verfassung ändern will der
muss anders mit uns umgehen der muss uns
einbeziehen in die diskussion und das
ist jetzt ihre politische und
parlamentarische aufgabe in den nächsten
wochen wenn die operation gelingen soll
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
der betriebskommission vorsitzenden der
unionsfraktion johann wadephul hat hier
unter anderem stark kritisiert wie die
tagesordnung morgen hier im deutschen
bundestag aussieht da wird in nämlich
der präsident der ukraine seelands die
zirka 20 minuten ab 9 uhr sprechen und
danach da geht es eben erst einmal um
ganz andere themen um sie in pflicht zum
beispiel die lage in der ukraine und der
flüchtlinge wird erst am nachmittag um
15 uhr in einer aktuellen stunde wieder
eine rolle spielen die
bundesinnenministerium ganzen feser ist
jetzt an der reihe
meine damen und herren herr dr wadephul
ich glaube es wäre schön gewesen
angesichts der dramatischen lage eines
krieges mitten in europa wenn sie ihre
rede dem thema so auch angepasst hätten
denn gerade jetzt ist es wichtig dass
wir demokratinnen und demokraten
zusammenstehen der russische überfall
auf die ukraine verursacht unfassbares
leid mitten in europa frauen und kinder
flüchten vor putins bomben und panzern
kinder verhungern und verdursten das hat
abgeordneter wagener sehr eindrucksvoll
hier gerade gesagt eben der das sieht
und spürt dieser tage dem zerreißt das
das herz meine damen und herren
dieser krieg ist eine furchtbare
humanitäre katastrophe putin lässt
krankenhäuser und wohnblocks
bombardieren fast drei millionen
geflüchtete haben sich bisher in die
nachbarstaaten der ukraine retten können
allen voran polen leistet großartiges
polen hat 1,2 millionen geflüchtete
aufgenommen und dafür sollten wir
unserem nachbarland auch sehr dankbar
sein
davon habe ich mir selbst vor wenigen
tagen an der polnisch ukrainischen
grenze ein bild machen können wir
unterstützen nicht nur die nachbarländer
wie polen sondern auch die ukraine und
die nachbarstaaten mit hilfstransporten
des thw mit medizin impfstoffen
feldbetten winter schlafsäcken innerhalb
weniger tage haben wir in der eu einen
historischen schulterschluss erreicht
alle eu-staaten nehmen gemeinsam schnell
und unbürokratisch geflüchtete auf das
ist wirklich eine großartige leistung
wir retten damit menschenleben
unabhängig vom pass für die allermeisten
geflüchteten gilt sie brauchen kein asyl
verfahren sie halten unmittelbar einen
schutzstatus der von anfang an
medizinische versorgung soziale
leistungen betreuung und schulbildung
der kinder ermöglicht wir beziehen die
verkehrsministerin minister unmittelbar
mit ein um schnelle weiterreisen auch zu
ermöglichen für menschen die zum
beispiel in spanien oder italien
verwandte und freunde haben der
schulterschluss aller eu-staaten zur
gemeinsamen aufnahme geflüchtet war bis
vor kurzem undenkbar all das zeigt dass
diese flucht bewegung mitten in europa
nicht vergleichbar ist mit vorherigen
fluchtbewegung auch nicht vergleichbar
mit 2015 dennoch das sage ich auch in
aller deutlichkeit werden wir das leid
der menschen die jetzt aus der ukraine
fliehen
mit dem leid anderer kriegsflüchtlinge
aufregen aber zugleich spüren wir doch
alle dieser tage dieser krieg ist uns so
nah es gibt enge familiäre verbindungen
viele geflüchtete werden von freunden
und verwandten abgeholt und versorgt
175.000 einreisen von geflüchteten
menschen aus der ukraine hat die
bundespolizei bislang gezielt die
erstaufnahme sind gerade stark belastet
wir arbeiten hier engstens zusammen um
schnell für entlastung und teilung zu
sorgen bund länder kommunen sind
gemeinsam in der verantwortung
es ist ein großer kraftakt den wir alle
zusammen stemmen werden
der bund unterstützt die länder massiv
mit dem thw mit einem deutlich
verstärkten einsatz der bundespolizei
und des bundesamtes für migration und
flüchtlinge
wir haben mit den ländern vereinbart
dass wir seit dieser woche nach dem
königsteiner schlüssel geflüchtete auf
die länder verteilt das betrifft
diejenigen die nicht privat in familien
oder bei bekannten untergebracht werden
und klar ist dass wir die länder und
kommunen damit nicht alleine lassen der
bund hat
zehntausende aufnahmeplätze mit
liegenschaften der beamer für die länder
und kommunen zur verfügung gestellt wir
sorgen dafür dass die zu uns
geflüchteten medizinisch gut versorgt
sind und zugang direkt zum arbeitsmarkt
erhalten indem wir so geflüchteten einen
sicheren alltag ermöglichen entlasten
wir auch die vielen familien die nun mit
großartiger hilfsbereitschaft
privatmenschen aufnehmen denen gilt mein
dank und den ganzen tausenden
ehrenamtlichen im moment in der
bundesrepublik die wirklich unfassbares
gerade für die menschen leisten
meine damen und herren natürlich schauen
wir jetzt genau hin wer nach deutschland
kommt die bundespolizei hat die
kontrolle an den grenzen den zügen und
an den bahnhöfen stark intensiviert die
polizeien der länder und die
bundespolizei in uniform ebenso wie in
zivil haben das geschehen genau im blick
sie arbeiten eng mit hilfsorganisationen
zusammen um frauen und kinder zu
schützen niemand darf deren notsituation
jetzt ausnutzen
meine damen und herren lassen wie ich
auch etwas zur registrierung in
deutschland sagen mir ist es wichtig
dass wir bei den fakten bleiben anders
als es von manchen zuletzt zu hören war
der ukraine rinnen und ukraine mit
biometrischen pass gilt visafreiheit für
90 tage sie sind nicht teil der eu aber
europäer wie wir sie dürfen frei reisen
das ist geltendes recht und das
ermöglicht auch dass viele bereits in
anderen europäischen staaten
weiterreisen konnten trotzdem haben wir
sehr schnell entschieden auch diese
menschen bei der erstaufnahme zu
registrieren und damit zum
frühstmöglichen zeitpunkt
registrierungs teams des bundesamtes für
migration und flüchtlinge unterstützen
berlin mit stationen zur erfassung der
daten der geflüchteten und das ist gut
so wir registrieren den erstaufnahme und
bei den ausländerbehörden das
intensivieren intensivieren wir weiter
die registrierung erfolgt spätestens
wenn menschen unterstützungsleistungen
in deutschland brauchen damit können wir
steuerung koordination und schnelle
hilfe für geflüchtete gewährleisten
meine damen und herren manche fordern
jetzt stationären grenzkontrollen an
unseren binnengrenzen was würde das
bedeuten
alte menschen frauen und kinder sind
meist 45 tage auf der flucht wenn sie
hierher kommt sie sind entkräftet und
traumatisiert wir wollen nicht dass
diese frauen und kinder weitere stunden
oder tage in der kälte hinter der
deutsch polnischen grenze campieren
müssen bevor sie mit dem nötigsten
versorgt werden können meine damen
wer jetzt grenzen schließen will
riskiert auf eine gute verteilung
innerhalb der eu wir brauchen keinen
populismus sondern pragmatische und
menschenwürdige lösung meine damen und
herren ich möchte auch hier im bundestag
klar sagen dieser krieg ist putins krieg
und nicht der krieg der menschen mit
russischen wurzeln die in deutschland
leben wir wehren uns ganz entschieden
dagegen dass menschen aufgrund ihrer
russischen herkunft angefeindet werden
dieser konflikt darf weder auf dem
rücken von ukrainerin ukrainern noch von
russinnen russen in deutschland
ausgetragen werden
unsere sicherheitsbehörden und unsere
polizei sind mit starken kräften im
einsatz und sehr wachsam sie schützen
jeden menschen in deutschland und jede
einrichtung gleichermaßen bei allen
einsatzkräften von polizei und thw bei
allen mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern in
den kommunen den ländern und
bundesbehörden bei allen freiwilligen
und ehrenamtlichen
möchte ich mich ganz herzlich bedanken
sie alle wachsen über sich hinaus und
zeigen eine großartige menschlichkeit
und solidarität eine menschlichkeit auf
die wir alle sehr stolz sein können
vielen dank
die rede der bundesebene minsterin nancy
faeser sie wurde ja in der vergangenheit
hier schon kritisiert er gab es kritik
dass es eben zu wenig koordination von
staatlicher seite gibt und natürlich ist
das für die städte hier schon eine
riesige aufgabe die geflüchteten auch
die ankommen unterzubringen
800 meter von hier am hauptbahnhof in
berlin sind allein gestern
1500 menschen angekommen und in die in
notunterkünfte dann aufgenommen werden
sollten matthias moosdorf spricht jetzt
für die afg fraktion meine damen und
herren liebe kollegen
wir alle stehen fassungslos inmitten
einer furchtbaren tragödie
kaum jemand wollte glauben dass ein
solcher zivilisationsbruch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert und in
unserer direkten nachbarschaft
stattfinden könnte unsere gedanken sind
bei den vielen opfern soldaten und
zivilisten beider seiten sie alle haben
familien wir fordern russland auf das
blutvergießen sofort einzustellen und
zurück zur vernunft also an den
verhandlungstisch zu kommen alle sollten
nach tod und zerstörung verstanden haben
dass nun wirklich verhandelt und
ergebnisse in beiderseitigen interesse
umgesetzt werden müssen
meine damen und herren 2014 trafen sich
die in den ersten weltkrieg verwickelten
staaten und versicherten aus der
geschichte gelernt zu haben niemals
wieder wollte man schlafwandlerischen
einen krieg schlittern
auseinandersetzung seien in einem
aufgeklärten jahrhundert friedlich
beizulegen
der krieg in der ukraine ist nun der
vorläufige höhepunkt einer langen reihe
von konflikten sehr viele davon wurden
vom westen begonnen vielleicht in guter
absicht aber mindestens töricht in ihrem
ausgang wir müssen uns heute fragen
warum das heraufziehende unheil trotz
vieler warnungen von joe biden bis
helmut schmidt von henry kissingers ist
peter scholl-latour von bill clinton bis
michael gorbatschow nicht politisch
verhindert wurde wo waren die lauten
proteste im westen als beginnen 2014
immer mehr menschen im don was
verschwunden sind wo war der druck der
internationalen gemeinschaft beide minsk
abkochen umzusetzen seit 2014 hatten
laut caritas zwei millionen ukrainer ihr
land verlassen die meisten richtung
russland die ukraine hat ihren
landsleuten im osten faktisch die
sprache genommen tv und rundfunk sender
geschlossen russischstämmige aus
leitenden positionen entfernt und sogar
die rentenzahlung eingestellt wo blieben
die proteste
schauen wir auch nicht weg wenn sie
scheinbar auf der richtigen seite die
falschen leute sammeln wer die videos
der soft privaten gesehen hat weiß wovon
die rede ist übrigens hat kollege gysi
in diesem bundestag diese leute als
faschisten bezeichnet meine damen und
herren ich bin in den letzten 30 jahren
beruflicher mehr als 65 ländern
unterwegs gewesen das bild welches wir
in deutschland von der welt zeichnen hat
sich beträchtlich von der wirklichkeit
entfernt politik und medien machen uns
glauben sanktionen und waffenlieferungen
seien nun die mittel der wahl
dieses verheerende denken verkennt das
ist in unserer heutigen welt keine
sieger und keine verlierer geben darf
nur ein empfindliches stets bedrohtes
gleichgewicht es ist ein schmaler grat
der uns von der apokalypse trend was
wenn es nicht darauf ankommt ob die
ukraine an putin feld sondern nur wann
und auf kosten wie viele opfer viele
junge männer auf beiden seiten wissen
nicht was krieg bedeutet es gehört zum
selbstverständnis freiheitliche
demokratien dass der start um der
menschen willen da zu sein hat und nicht
umgekehrt
das opfer des lebens widerspricht der
menschenwürde die über allen politischen
interessen stets das ist verantwortung
meine damen und herren
der israelische ministerpräsident so
wird in einigen medien berichtet soll
präsident sie den ski geraten haben
einzulangen zu lenken nicht aus schwäche
aber aus vernunft beide seiten müssen
jetzt gesichts waren aus der sache
herauskommen und vor allem die müssen
wir dafür sorge tragen dass die nato
nicht in den krieg hineingezogen wird
die fdp lehnt wirtschaftssanktionen ab
wir werden damit will ich ein umdenken
erreichen aber uns gewaltig schaden
durch eigene sonderwege hat sich
deutschland alleine schon in die
energiepolitische abhängigkeit begeben
und es ist überhaupt kein zweifel dass
unsere bundeswehr durch schon zu lange
feministische verteidigungspolitik quasi
ruiniert wurde das ist die lage meine
damen und herren es ist zutiefst
verstörend wenn soziale netze in diesem
moment hast kommentare gegen russland
erlauben nicht überall nur in den
ländern in denen eine eskalation dieses
krieges zuerst erfolgen glaube es ist
verstörend dass menschen mit russischen
und ukrainischen wurzeln in deutschland
angst haben müssen weil russische
schulen wie in berlin angegriffen und
künstler diffamiert werden weil
restaurants schilder aufhängen russen
unerwünscht und kinder aus dem
kindergarten nach hause geschickt werden
ich erinnere an den ausspruch von
hendrik oder wenn ihr euch fragt wie es
damals dazu kommen konnte nun weil sie
damals so waren wie er es heute seid
helfen wir lieber was in der ukraine mit
klugen politischen mittel ein
interessenausgleich möglich wird der
krieg hat russen und ukrainer für
mindestens eine generation unrettbar
entfremdet der mutige widerstand
präsident sie lenski stattdessen einen
neu gründungsmythos für sein land
liefern aber die menschen in der ost
ukraine sollten mit internationaler
beobachtung selbst abstimmen und an
welchen bach sie leben wollen wenn wir
ehrlich sind gibt es dazu keine
alternative auch nicht auf der krim es
ist die wirklichkeit die zählt und nicht
unser wunsch die wirklichkeit möge eine
andere sein und meine damen und herren
es gibt nur ein gebot der stunde
frieden zu stiften ist die große aufgabe
europas ich danke ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit
der fdp politiker matthias moosdorf war
das und während er hier gesprochen hat
kann hier die meldung ein dass der
internationale gerichtshof in den haag
auf eine dringlichkeit klage der ukraine
gegen russland ein urteil gefällt hat in
der das gericht er sagt dass russland
den krieg gegen die ukraine stoppen muss
allerdings hat der internationale
gerichtshof keine machtmittel um einen
staat zu seinem urteil zu zwingen auch
wenn die urteile finden sind das also
nur als information für sie hier gezielt
debatte weiter alexander graf lambsdorff
spricht jetzt für die fdp fraktion
scheint als habe sich der russische
präsident in genau diese tradition
gestellt er benutzt geschichte als
ideologie ersatz sie als waffe und
manipuliert sie dazu nach belieben mit
der lüge das land
entnazifizierung zu wollen hat putin die
ukraine am 24 februar
2022 rücksichtslos überfallen mit der
lüge es handele sich um eine
spezialoperation versucht er die
wahrheit eines großen land kriegs vor
seinem eigenen volk zu verbergen mit der
lüge die opposition schwäche russland
drangsaliert der demokraten
journalistinnen und aktivisten die
vergiftet weggesperrt ja ermordet werden
meine damen und herren lassen sie mich
das so klar sagen wer dieser tage ware
russische patrioten sehen will der darf
nicht im kreml suchen der mussten die
jetzt geschlossenen redaktionsstuben von
durst und von novarra basierter schauen
im schauprozess auf den alten
angeklagten alexei navalny und in die
gesichter der demonstrantinnen im
angesicht jeden tag runder beachtung dem
russischen diktator die stirn bieten sie
sind die wahren patrioten sie schreiben
die ehrenvolle geschichte ihres landes
denn sie lehnen den verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
rundheraus ab doch putin wiederholt
immer wieder er wolle die ukraine
entnazifizierung diese ukraine die von
einem präsidenten aus einer jüdischen
familie derzeit so großartig regiert und
repräsentiert wird einem präsidenten der
zahlreiche verwandte im holocaust
verloren hat einen präsidenten der eine
gesellschaftspolitische liberale agenda
verfolgt anders als russland das immer
intoleranter und repressiver regiert
wird diese ukraine meine damen und
herren die muss niemand entnazifizierung
diese ukraine ist ein großer nachbar der
europäischen union der bei allen
problemen doch immer wieder
demokratische wahlen abgehalten und
friedliche machtwechsel vollzogen hat
ein demokratisches land mit anderen
worten die ukraine ist ein land in dem
die presse die regierung kritisieren ja
verspotten darf in dem demonstrationen
erlaubt sind und aktivist nicht
weggesperrt werden ein freies land mit
anderen worten demokratie und freiheit
für diese werte für westliche werte für
unsere werte sterben jeden tag menschen
in der ukraine wir alle sehen das leid
der menschen in kiew und car kit und vor
allem in mario pohl wie auch in anderen
teilen des landes in unseren nachrichten
ist von panzerkolonnen
kampfflugzeugen marschflugkörpern die
rede sogar die realen die verschwundene
realität der nuklearen bedrohung taucht
im bewusstsein wieder auf es ist kein
wunder dass hier bei uns in deutschland
viele menschen schockiert verängstigt
und aufgewühlt auf diese ereignisse
blicken wie oft wurde es doch in den
vergangenen jahren als sonntagsrede
belächelt wenn jemand auf den wert des
friedens des einigen europa und unserer
einbettung in das atlantische bündnis
garantien unserer freiheit und unserer
demokratie hinwies schlagartig verstehen
viele wie wichtig allianzen bündnisse
vertrauen ja sogar freundschaften zu
anderen ländern wie frankreich und den
usa sind manche hatten das schon früher
verstanden der damalige bundespräsident
joachim gauck fragten nach der aktion
der krim und dem russischen einmarsch in
der ost ukraine 2014 auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
ich zitiere hat deutschland die neuen
gefahren und die veränderung im gefüge
der internationalen ordnung schon
angemessen wahrgenommen er greift die
bundesrepublik genügend initiative um
jenes geflecht aus normen freunden und
allianzen zukunftsfähig zu machen das
uns doch frieden freiheit und wohlstand
in demokratie gebracht hat acht jahre
ist das her und seien wir ehrlich
warnende stimmen in den letzten jahr die
sich kritisch mit putins politik und der
realen gefahr eines zusammenbruchs
unserer internationalen ordnung
auseinandergesetzt haben wurden nicht
gehört sechs jahre nach diesen fragen
des bundespräsidenten sechs jahre nach
dem sogenannten münchner konsens sprach
der bericht der sicherheitskonferenz von
einer weltpolitischen zeitenwende die
autoren sackten klar was europa tun
müsste im angesicht wachsender russische
aggression und zwar verteidigungen
abschreckung stärken resilienz aufbauen
doch das ist auch 2020 nicht geschehen
die fragen von joachim gauck waren
vergessen der münchner konsens verpufft
das ist meine damen und herren heute
anders die bundesregierung hat
ausweislich der rede des bundeskanzlers
vom 27 februar die tatsache der
zeitenwende erfasst und dass sie eine
politische wende gestaltet wir sind eng
mit unseren internationalen partnern
zusammen gerückt russland wird durch
harte sanktionen wirtschaftlich
finanziell und politisch isoliert wir
liefern waffen in ein kriegsgebiet wir
unterstützen die ukraine und wir
versetzen die bundeswehr endlich wieder
in den stand ihrer verfassungsmäßigen
aufgaben nachzukommen
meine damen und herren machen wir uns
nichts vor der heißen krieg in der
ukraine ist teil eines größeren globalen
kalten der auseinandersetzung zwischen
freiheit rechtsstaat und demokratie
einerseits unterdrückung willkür und
diktatur andererseits so sind die
tatsachen und keine lüge des russischen
präsidenten kann uns vom gegenteil
überzeugen deutschland wird kurz halten
zusammen mit den anderen freien nationen
die unsere werte teilen wir bleiben bei
der wahrheit wir weisen die lüge zurück
wir stehen heute und in zukunft fest an
der der ukraine einig herzlichen dank
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp fraktion
alexander graf lambsdorff war dass auf
ihn folgt nun dietmar bartsch der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
sie denn meine damen und herren
seit 21 tagen wird die ukraine von
russischen truppen angegriffen seit 21
tagen sterben ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
frauen und kinder durch russische
artillerie- und russische raketen
wladimir putin trägt die verantwortung
für tod und leid für angst für
rücksichtslose zerstörung und
millionenfache vertreiben mehr als drei
millionen menschen haben ihre heimat
bereits hinter sich gelassen allein in
warschau
es sind 15 prozent mehr einwohner als
ende februar die ministerin hat zu recht
dass lobend erwähnt wie dort damit
umgegangen sind aber auch 500 meter von
hier luftlinie
kommen am berliner hauptbahnhof jeden
tag tausende frauen und kinder aus der
ukraine an
erschöpft mit nicht mehr als handgepäck
und der schultasche der kinder
dass hier im bundestag so oft
gescholtene berlin verdient leistet
herausragendes und verdient unser aller
dank meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir nicht mehr
im keller chiefs oder faktisch um sein
leben bank findet in den nachbarländern
und auch bei uns schutz aber was meine
damen und herren muss dieses unfassbare
gefühl sein alles zurückzulassen und
nicht zu wissen was die nächsten tage
und wochen bringen
mein name und herren unterstützen wir
aber auch die russinnen und russen die
maximalen mut gegen putins krieg sich
stellen im freundeskreis und auf der
straße der mut von marina offs janika
war ist beeindruckend was für eine tolle
mutige frau
viele russen und russen sind wütend
wollen das sterben ihrer brüder und
schwestern nicht hin leben auch wenn sie
mit 15 jahren gefängnis bedroht werden
ich habe in moskau promoviert zusammen
mit russen zusammen mit ukraine in einem
seminar wir haben zusammen sport gemacht
wir haben zusammen gefeiert
und ich bin ob des krieges fassungslos
und ich bin auch wütend und entsetzt
dass das passieren kann aber auch die
russinnen und russen und im land die
sprache die russische literatur und die
musik die alle tragen keine schuld und
jeglicher angriff auf sie müssen unseren
entschiedenen widerspruch erfolg
viele verlieren
es gibt keine rechtfertigung für diesen
krieg putins keine entschuldigung nicht
die ukraine nicht die nato haben aus
einem schwelbrand ein entfernen gemacht
sondern der russische präsident er
allein es auch in der pflicht diesen
grausamen angriffskrieg zu beenden
sofort zu beenden und sehr geehrter herr
bundeskanzler
sehr geehrte frau ministerin
so kritisch wie manche schlussfolgerung
aus dem krieg sehen jeder versucht den
sie unternehmen diesen krieg mit
diplomatischen bemühungen zu beenden den
unterstützen wir jede reise die sie
unternehmen die das sterben mitten in
europa beendet hat die ausdrückliche
unterstützung meiner fraktion aber auch
jede sanktionierung die sand in putins
kriegsmaschine streut und oligarchen
sanktioniert die das system putin
stützen hat unsere zustimmung
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich sage
ihnen aber auch die reaktionen auf die
größte flucht bewegung seit 1945 lief zu
zaghaft während am berliner hauptbahnhof
schon tausende täglich aus den zügen
stiegen sagte die innenminister noch am
9 märz eine verteilung von geflüchteten
aus der ukraine nach quoten wäre nicht
nötig was für ein fataler irrtum werden
die bürgerinnen und bürger sich vielfach
auf opfern spenden zimmer in ihren
wohnungen frei räumen hat die
bundesregierung zu lange gewartet es ist
richtig dass jetzt endlich ein schlüssel
vorliegt eine gerechte verteilung ist
nicht an einem interesse unseres landes
sondern zuvorderst im interesse auch der
ankommenden die optimale betreuung und
vor allem auch perspektiven brauchen
gerade auch die so geschundenen kinder
sehen wir brauchen chancen für diese
kinder und mütter sprachkurse und
umfassende betreuung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die ukraine ist ein
souveränes land es muss alles
unternommen werden dass die ukraine ein
souveränes und freies land bleiben wenn
dieser krieg endet muss die ukraine
wissen dass wir sie nicht im regen
stehen lassen die menschen die sich
jetzt bei uns in sicherheit wissen
müssen vertrauen dass wir ihnen beim
wiederaufbau helfen das heißt wir werden
ein marshallplan ukraine dringend
brauchen sehr geehrte damen und herren
die bundesregierung allein kann den
krieg nicht beenden aber sie ist eine
verantwortung die kriegsfolgen für die
menschen in deutschland abzufedern dazu
haben sie die möglichkeit auch damit die
willkommenskultur erhalten bleibt und da
sage ich ihnen auch dass da ihr heutiges
entlastungspaket nicht ausreichend ist
wir brauchen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger die unter den kriegsfolgen
leidenden dringend jetzt entlastung
schnell unbürokratisch und wirksam
die forderung von dietmar bartsch war
dass svenja schulze spricht jetzt die
bundesministerin für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung eine von
drei bundesministerinnen die sich hier
in dieser aktuellen stunde zu wort
melden
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
putins krieg gegen die ukraine
verursacht unermessliches leid
unermessliches leid für frauen für
männer für kinder und die russischen
angriffe verschärfen jeden tag diese
humanitäre krise immer mehr millionen
von menschen sind inzwischen auf der
flucht rund die hälfte von ihnen sind
kinder
viele dieser kinder müssen den weg
alleine gehen ohne ihre eltern ohne eine
bezugsperson ich konnte mir das am
montag in sie geht an der rumänisch
ukrainischen grenze ansehen was die
bilder die verfolgen mich weiterhin das
ist wirklich eine bedrückende situation
mich hat an dieser grenze die
persönliche geschichte
der familie mit denen ich dort reden
konnte sehr beeindruckt ich habe noch
sehr in erinnerung die geschichte von
svetlana die mit ihren beiden söhnen mit
ihrer mutter tatjana
sechs tage lang sich aus der süd ukraine
an die grenze durchgeschlagen hat wo die
kinder mehr erzählt haben wie sie die
nächte im keller mit dem bunten erlebt
haben wie sie die einschläge immer noch
spüren stille kinder die leise spielen
weil sie angst haben vor weiteren bomben
das ist das was man dort sehen kann und
man sieht welche großartige hilfe unicef
dort jeden tag leistet svetlana wird mit
ihren kindern jetzt sehr schnell weitere
reisen nach madrid aber sie wird genau
wie die ganzen anderen frauen dort an
der grenze die frage mitnehmen wie es
ihren männern geht und wann sie endlich
wieder sehen kann mich beeindruckt wie
viele menschen an der rumänischen an der
polnischen einer moldawischen grenze
sich unermüdlich im einsatz befinden um
den geflüchteten mensch so helfen wie
viele hier in deutschland
engagiert sind mich beeindruckt die
große solidarität die wir hier sehen die
wir aber auch europa und weltweit sehen
und ich bin froh das nennt sich phaser
innenministerin ist dass sie diese ganze
arbeit mit den ländern koordiniert und
dass wir gemeinsam diese herausforderung
auch wirklich bewältigen
deren und hernals bundesregierung werden
wir natürlich so schnell es geht
beiträge leisten um das akute leid zu
lindern
perspektiven für die menschen aus der
ukraine aufzuzeigen im
entwicklungsministerium sofort reagiert
und sehr schnell und 45 millionen euro
umgeschichtet um unmittelbar an der
grenze unmittelbar vor ort zu helfen
annalena baerbock hat dem
außenministerium in gleicher höhe sofort
auch geholfen wir sind vor ort wir sind
schnell bei den menschen helfen beim
katastrophenschutz bei der feuerwehr bei
hilfsmaßnahmen für menschen auf der
flucht und vor allen dingen eben für die
vielen kinder und frauen wir müssen aber
auch den blick über die ukraine hinaus
über die eu hinaus richten es gilt die
ökonomischen die sozialen auswirkungen
des krieges weltweit abzufedern
besonders in den entwicklungs in den
krisenländern müssen die die spirale der
destabilisierung verhindern denn ein
euro als investition in krisenfeste
gesellschaften spart später vier euro an
humanitärer
hilfe und die wahrscheinlichen die
mutmaßlichen auswirkungen auf die
welternährung die sind dramatisch die
das entwicklungsministerium handelt hier
im engen schulterschluss mit dem außen
mit dem landwirtschaftsministerium und
ich will ausdrücklich noch einmal cem
özdemir danken dass er das thema auch
zum thema bei g7 gemacht hat uns geht es
darum mit unseren partnern jetzt
möglichst schnell die internationalen
unterstützungsprogramme hochzufahren
drohende hungersnot jetzt möglichst noch
vermeiden zu helfen aber
kolleginnen und kollegen uns allen ist
bewusst mittel und langfristig brauchen
wir nachhaltige agra nachhaltige
ernährungssystem das ist eine antwort
auf den klimawandel die ja ohnehin der
klimawandel ist ja ohnehin treiber des
weltweiten hungers und deswegen müssen
wir in zukunft die abhängigkeiten
reduzieren und dominoeffekte vermeiden
ein weiterer bereich in dem die
auswirkung des krieges heute schon
spürbar sind und zwar weltweit das sind
die energiepreise das sehen wir alle
hier an den zapfsäulen und dann auch auf
den stromrechnungen aber das gleiche
gilt auch weltweit die abhängigkeit von
fossilen energieimporten macht auch
viele entwicklungsländer sehr sehr
verwundbar
erneuerbare energien sind freiheits
energien hat christian lindner
richtigerweise gesagt erneuerbare
energien sind aber auch
entwicklungsländern sie machen die
entwicklungs versorgung wie man die
energieversorgung sicherer bezahlbarer
und sie machen die entwicklungsländer
unabhängiger eine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die diese
energien ausbaut das ist dann auch
wieder krisenvorsorge und deswegen setze
ich mich setzt sich die bundesregierung
für einen massiven ausbau der klima und
entwicklungspartnerschaften 1 das ist
ein ganz wichtiger beitrag für den
frieden und für die sozial ökologische
transformation
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen dieser
krieg dieser krieg
dieser krieg hat keine gewinne aber
dieser krieg hat sehr sehr viele
verlierer neben den menschen in der
ukraine viele andere auf der ganzen welt
insbesondere die ärmsten und deswegen
erfordert der krieg neben der
militärischen auch starke zivile
antworten beides gehört zusammen
entwicklungspolitik und das müssen sie
sich hier anhören entwicklungspolitik
leistet einen wichtigen beitrag zur
neuen sicherheitspolitik der
bundesregierung
und auch
wenn sie das nicht hören wollen in liegt
entwicklungspolitik ist gerade jetzt
enorm wichtig wir müssen solidarisch wir
müssen auch den menschen in den ärmsten
ländern dieser welt helfen das system
falls die auffassung dieser
bundesregierung erhöht sich nur dann
der nächste redner in dieser aktuellen
stunde ist michael brandt ist schon in
der legislaturperiode zuvor sprecher für
menschenrechte hat eine familie gewesen
wie jetzt auch auf
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen diese debatte ist nicht vor
allem eine debatte über europäische
sicherheit über die sicherheit unseres
landes das ist sie auch aber sie ist vor
allem eine debatte über die brutalsten
menschenrechtsverletzungen europa seit
dem genozid in bosnien in der ukraine
finden unaussprechliche kriegsverbrechen
stadt
angeordnet von einem kriegsverbrecher in
europa auch deutschland nicht konsequent
davon abgehalten hat diese
kriegsverbrechen vorzubereiten und
umzusetzen
und ich möchte es für mich als
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages
und als einer der seit dem krieg in
bosnien herzegowina weiß wie
kriegsverbrechen konkret aussehen was
sie mit menschen machen für das
protokoll festhalten ich schäme mich
dafür dass wir die deutschen die in
ihrer geschichte in der ukraine so
unaussprechlichen kriegsverbrechen
begangen haben die ukraine nicht früh
genug geschützt und uns mit dem
kriegsverbrecher zu lange gemein gemacht
haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir waren
zu spät wir waren zu schwach herr
bundeskanzler
die bundesregierung hat beim thema
defensive waffen zu lange gezögert auch
bei swift und deutschland zögert noch
immer es wird gebremst bei weiteren
sanktionen in der eu beim stopp weiterer
energielieferungen aus russland die
putins kriegt ja mitfinanzieren und
unser land ist bei humanitärer hilfe
schon wieder zu spät liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die verteidigung von
freiheit und menschenrechte hat ihren
preis den wir bereit sein müssen zu
zahlen wären menschen in der ukraine
dies in diesen stunden mit ihrem leben
bezahlen
und neben der verteidigung der ukraine
brauchen millionen kriegs flüchtige
flüchtlinge unsere konkrete
unterstützung und besonders müssen wir
die wohlhabenden gruppen oder den
flüchtlingen schützen wir haben vor
wenigen tagen mit einer staatsanwälte
mit streetworkern anderen über die
akuten gefahren für mädchen und frauen
gesprochen in freier foren in diesen
stunden berichten deutsche männer
freudig von neuen ukrainischen frauen in
ihren stamm buddeln ich erspare ihnen
details zum thema menschenhandel wir
sind zielland vor allen dingen von den
frauen die opfer werden aus osteuropa
wir sind das größte bordell europas
nämlich hier in deutschland und die
details sind strikt schrecklich ich sag
das aus einem grund frau
bundesinnenministerium nicht will sie
direkt ansprechen
sie haben von registrierungen gesprochen
sie registrieren zu langsam und zu wenig
umfassend das ist die realität wenn sie
heute an die polnische grenze gehen und
einem dank an die polnische regierung
für das was sie dort tut dann erleben
sie dass die flüchtlinge direkt
registriert werden im übrigen mit einer
deutschen software die wir hier nicht
einsetzen und das was sie sagen dass wir
an der erstaufnahme und dann bei der
beantragung von leistungen die
flüchtlinge registrieren hat ein problem
in dem zeitfenster das ist das eldorado
für die menschenhändler weil wir wissen
dann gar nicht ob die frauen und die
kinder wechseln und deswegen müssen wir
einst sicherstellen dass die frauen
nicht im krieg entkommen sind und
anschließend in der zwangsprostitution
in deutschland und deswegen liebe frau
ministerin feser und auch an die
familienministerin spiegel wir fordern
sie auf tun sie endlich alles um schnell
und und diese frauen vor schwersten
menschenrechtsverletzungen zu bewahren
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen was
ist denn eigentlich los wir debattieren
über die ukraine ein minister nach dem
anderen aus dem kabinett scholz geht ans
mikrofon man lobt sich gegenseitig und
der bundeskanzler schweiz
und herr bundeskanzler scholz ihre
innenminister hat von haltungen
gesprochen ich muss das schon sagen
haltung wäre es gewesen vor drei wochen
haben wir hier im deutschen bundestag in
großer einigkeit und die opposition
deutlich gemacht dass wir an der seite
stehen in dieser schweren stunde das
parlament ist aufgestanden vor allem
ukrainischen botschafter hat minutenlang
applaudiert es wäre an ihnen gewesen
heute für die bundesregierung sich zu
entschuldigen bei diesem mutigen
botschafter der seinen job macht und
diesem staatssekretär zu entlassen
und ich muss das sagen ich bin schon
einigermaßen sprachlos dass ein
präsident die lenski ich habe einen
solchen respekt wie viele in unserem
land vor diesem mann dass wir morgen in
der debatte eine video-konferenz so eine
zuschaltung haben und anschließend über
die impfpflicht diskutieren sollen herr
bundeskanzler ich glaube das ist nicht
der richtige weg es ist der alle die
allerhöchste zeit dass die
bundesregierung mehr tut eine
historische regierungserklärung alleine
reicht nicht wir fordern von ihnen dass
sie sich der historischen verantwortung
stellen wir können einen unterschied
machen und wir müssen alles tun um den
opfern dieses krieges zu helfen und
diesen krieg möglichst rasch zu beenden
michael brandt war das hat hier noch
einmal den schutz der besonders
wohlhabenden und gruppen angemahnt das
ist in dieser krise in diesem krieg
besonders wichtig nach angaben der
vereinten nationen sind bislang in seit
den letzten knapp drei wochen mehr als
drei millionen menschen geflüchtet und
davon sind die hälfte der geflüchteten
kinder annalena baerbock spricht jetzt
die bundes außenministerin deutschlands
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen man spürt förmlich in diesem
raum für uns alle sind die bilder aus
der ukraine nicht zu ertragen und für
uns sind es nur bilder für die million
menschen vor ort sind sie bittere
realität
und daher ist für uns alle dass das gute
zeichen ganz klar das allerwichtigste
ist die russische und ich sagen klar die
russische bombardierung von unschuldigen
menschen muss aufhören
und es ist gut und wichtig dass es jetzt
gespräche zwischen der ukraine und
russland gibt aber auch hier müssen wir
vor uns selber ehrlich sein wir wissen
nicht ob das wirklich gespräche sind ein
diktat frieden hat wenig mit frieden zu
tun und wir sollten uns nichts vormachen
wenn die einen über friedensgespräche
reden und zeitgleich krankenhäuser und
wohngebäude bombardieren dann geht es
wohl nicht wirklich um gespräche und
nichtsdestotrotz telefoniert der kanzler
nichtsdestotrotz führen wir diese
gespräche nichtsdestotrotz obwohl wir
schon mal belogen wurden touren wir
alles was wir können wissentlich dass es
vielleicht in diesem moment nicht das
bringt was wir alle wollen ein ende
dieser bombardierung und man muss hier
einmal klar und deutlich sagen es gibt
nicht zwei seiten es gibt eine seite es
gibt sogar nur einen präsidenten der
diese bombardierung zu verantworten hat
und das ist der russische kritik
und es ist furchtbar es ist einfach nur
furchtbar
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass
dieser krieg immer zynischer immer
brutaler wird putins feigen krieg stehen
nichtsdestotrotz ein unglaublicher mut
der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer gegenüber
putins und es ist allein putins krieg
verlogen verlogenen krieg gegenüber
steht ein wahrheit' wille der vielen
russischen und bella russischen
bürgerinnen und bürger die auf die
straße gehen die einen militär dienst
quittieren
wissentlich dass sie dafür ihre eigene
freiheit ihre eigene sicherheit aufs
spiel setzen und ich verneige mich und
ich glaube wir verneigen uns vor ihrem
mut
body street und dass es das einzig
kleine bisschen gute putins einsamkeit
gegenüber steht eine geschlossene
europäische und internationale
gemeinschaft aber
und das ist bitter es ist wie gesagt
kaum zu ertragen es ist auch so dass es
allein putin in der hand hat diesen
grausamen krieg jetzt zu beenden dass
mark uns wütend dass mark uns
fassungslos machen aber es macht uns
nicht hilflos wir haben gemeinsam
deswegen alles was wir tun könnt
machtpolitisch darauf konzentriert
dieses macht system putins zu treffen wo
wir es treffen können ja mit
waffenlieferungen und da so eine debatte
auch sinn und zweck hat fragen zu
stellen vorwürfe gegen die regierung
dafür ist diese debatte da möchte ich
versuchen einiges von ihnen was sie auch
angesprochen hatten aufzugreifen wir
liefen sting beliefern strehler aber wir
können jedoch nicht herbeizaubern wenn
sie jetzt sagen liefern sie mal mehr die
verteidigungsministerin hat geguckt was
wir liefern können und zur ehrlichkeit
gehört auch dazu wir haben nicht genug
deswegen haben wir uns im kopf
zerbrochen wie können wir das anders
machen wir haben über die european peace
facility im übrigen weil wir eine andere
debatte führen finanziert vor allen
dingen auch über das auswärtige amt
gelder zur verfügung gestellt damit mit
diesen geldern die ukraine direkt beim
rüstungskonzern selber einkaufen kann
wir tun alles dafür dass diese einkäufe
jetzt ganz ganz schnell ohne
bürokratische hürden sonst prüfen wir ja
zwischen drei ressorts hin und her
vonstatten gehen können glauben sie mir
wir tun alles und wenn wir zaubern
könnten wenn wir mehr waffen liefern
könnten dann würden wir das tun und wir
tun es auch bei den sanktionen
wir tun's auch bei den sanktionen aber
ich hatte das ja schon mal gesagt mit
blick auf swift was bringt uns eine
sanktion wo alle sagen juhu das ist die
neue sanktion und wir wissen wir können
sie in dem moment nicht umsetzen
deswegen haben wir bei stifter prüft wie
kennen wir banken die kappen wie können
wir dafür sorgen dass wir wirklich
schnell ins system kommen und es wirkt
wir haben heute die berichte im
sicherheitskabinett bzw im kabinett
gehabt 50% rubel verfall wir haben
gehört dass die staatsanleihen dass
kredite nicht gezahlt werden können weil
man vollkommen abgeschottet ist vom
finanzierungssystem und wir haben ich
glaube das wissen eigentlich alle
gestern ein viertes sanktionspaket auf
den weg gebracht wo wir vor allen dingen
schaut haben wie schließen wir die lücke
da wo funktion umgangen werden weil das
bringen uns die schönsten sanktionen
wenn wir fünf länder haben die sich
nicht daran halten dass es doch jetzt
die aufgabe nicht immer mehr nicht immer
lauter das team hat diese und effektiver
jetzt wirklich dieses dem zu stecken
und so sehr wir uns einig sind so sehr
wir uns einig sind das ja auch das
besondere in diesem moment das waren wir
uns noch nie bei solchen verteidigungs
rüstungs politischen fragen jetzt sind
wir uns einig das ist gut dass wir mehr
geld in die hand nehmen müssen auch für
die sicherheit der bundeswehr aber auch
hier die debatte führen wir hier noch
und ehrlich gesagt freude ist kein wort
dass man sagen kann aber ich glaube es
wird eine gute debatte gemeinsam darüber
zu überlegen nicht nur wie wir erhöhen
wir den verteidigungsetat darüber dass
wir ein sondervermögen machen sondern
wie formulieren wir eine
sicherheitsstrategie die wirklich trägt
nicht nur in diesem moment sondern auch
in den nächsten jahren wo vernetzte
sicherheit eben auch bedeutet seiner
fähigkeiten zu haben und die
sachkompetenz haben wahrscheinlich nicht
die streitkräfte sondern andere akteure
in unserem land diese debatte die haben
wir nie geführt jetzt ist der moment sie
zu führen und die gelder richtig zur
verfügung zu stellen und ich glaube wir
haben eine super leute in allen
fraktionen die hervorragend diese
debatten jetzt schon
und dann gilt für mich aber auch und das
zeigt sich ja gerade das zeigt doch auch
dass wir deutschen manches richtig
gemacht haben warum konnten wir andere
länder in diesem moment überzeugen an
unserer seite zu stehen nicht nur aus
wirtschaftlichen interesse nicht nur aus
gründen zu sagen weil es
verteidigungspolitisch geboten ist weil
sie uns vertrauen weil es gewirkt hat
dass wir jahrelang in diplomatie in gute
beziehung in zuhören investiert haben
und vielleicht der kleine seiten schlenk
fall auch mich bewegt dass ich habe auch
gedacht soll morgen reagieren oder nicht
wir haben cola zugeschaltet im nato-rat
haben wir dann die dating danach ja oder
nein natürlich zerbrechen uns den kopf
ich glaube in so einem moment ist zu
hören eine echte stärke zu hören das
wort stehen lassen auch die vorwürfe es
geben wird stehen lassen ich glaube dass
es im moment farbe größe und und unserer
stärke bewusst zu sein und dies auch
diplomatie und deswegen möchte ich mir
jetzt viel bei verteidigung sicherheit
gesprochen deutlich machen und da
brauchen wir sie auch alle da brauchen
wir den haushaltsausschuss vor allen
dingen da wo wir bedingungslos helfen
können da müssen wir jetzt bedingungslos
helfen wir können das in manchen
bereichen nicht weil wir wirtschaftliche
abhängigkeiten haben aber wir können es
im humanitären bereich und deswegen
möchte ich drei punkte hier einmal
erwähnen für die nächsten wochen
erstens humanitäre hilfe meine kollegin
svenja schulze hat das angesprochen die
versorgungslage ist dramatisch kiew
marie provokativ unwahrscheinlich wird
kiew jetzt noch mal härter getroffen wir
brauchen mehr geld danke dass wir heute
zusätzlich 350 millionen euro auf den
weg gebracht haben wir werden leider
weitere gelder im bereich humanitärer
unterstützung brauchen der zweite punkt
ist in dem verteidigungs- und europa
ausschuss habe ich das heute schon
gesagt unterstützung der nachbarländer
wir sehen was die alle leisten und vor
allen dingen moldau die große
sicherheitsgefahr ist dass das kleine
moldau ohne panzer ohne irgendwelche
militärische aktion plötzlich auch mit
einverleibt wird weil sie ihre
stromversorgung nicht mehr aufrecht
halten wir können da helfen das heißt
auch hier stabilisierungs hilfe auf den
weg zu bringen und bereit dazu sein kann
rollt auf uns drauf
und mein dritter punkt ist mein dritter
punkt ist die verteilung der
geflüchteten im inland müssen wir
gemeinsam schauen wo wir besser werden
kommunen länder ja und auch auf
bundesebene
aber wir haben auch eine verantwortung
an der außengrenze wenn man sieht was da
passiert ist es sind in den letzten
tagen diejenigen kombi ein auto hatten
die verwandte in europa haben jetzt
kommen diejenigen die niemand mehr haben
ich habe eine 80 jährige frau in moldau
betroffen ich habe mich gar nicht die
frage getraute stellen aber ich habe sie
trotzdem gefragt wo wollen sie hin und
sie hat gesagt in den himmel ich habe
niemand mehr wo soll ich in europa noch
hin wir können nicht sagen die sollte
ich freiwillig verteilt diese frau wird
er im zweifel einfach sitzen bleiben auf
ihrem stuhl deswegen ist es jetzt unsere
aufgabe gemeinsam für eine
solidarische brücke zu sorgen in europa
und über den transatlantik und das ist
auch mein appell
freunde in kanada 18
wir müssen jetzt menschen von der
außengrenze verteilen können wir
bedingungslos helfen herzlichen dank
us-außenministerin
baerbock war das hat in ihrer rede auch
die schwierigkeiten eingeräumt die
bundesregierung bei der reaktion auf
diesen krieg hat international sowie
auch innerhalb deutschlands
der nächste redner kommt aus nordrhein
westfalen joachim
stammt ist minister für kinder familien
flüchtlinge und integration
und der stellvertretende
ministerpräsident und spricht jetzt hier
für den bundesrat
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren der bombenterror
wladimir putins soll nicht nur die moral
der ukraine brechen die bombardierung
von
kindergärten von krankenhäusern von
wohnblocks und
mittlerweile auch von flüchtlings
einrichtungen diese bombardierung soll
menschen systematisch
vertreiben und es ist offensichtlich
dass der vertreibungs terror teil einer
strategie ist
eine strategie die uns die europäischen
nachbarländer de stabilisieren soll und
die unsere gesellschaften spalten soll
dadurch dass möglichst viele derjenigen
die vor den bomben fliehen müssen in die
europäischen länder kommen und meine
damen und herren es ist jetzt unsere
gemeinsame aufgabe
wir müssen jetzt genau so beweisen wie
die ukraine die sich nicht brechen lässt
dass auch wir uns nicht brechen lassen
in unserer solidarität und wir
gemeinsam mit den partnern in europa in
internationaler solidarität unserer
historischen aufgabe gerecht werden und
die vertriebenen alle aufnehmen
meine damen und herren ich habe jedoch
den eindruck dass sich nicht alle auch
in europa nicht alle der historischen
dimension dieser aufgabe bewusst sind
insbesondere ist es eben schon
angesprochen worden polen leistet
herausragendes
aber wenn sie sich allein in warschau
300.000 vertriebene aufhalten in breslau
sind es 200.000
in berlin täglich über 10.000 menschen
ankommen dann muss jetzt dann muss
sofort gehandelt werden eine historische
aufgabe
eine historische aufgabe braucht eine
historische antwort
und ich möchte sie herr bundeskanzler
dringend bitten auf den französischen
präsidenten zuzugehen und noch in dieser
woche einen europäischen gipfel
vorzubereiten der eine evakuierung
hunderttausender direkt aus polen in die
verschiedenen europäischen länder
ermöglicht wir brauchen eine luftbrücke
aus polen und wir brauchen sie so
schnell wie möglich so wie einst die
berliner luftbrücke sich stalins terror
entgegengestellt hat sollte europa mit
einer luftbrücke sich heute dem terror
putins entgegenstellen
und ich sage das ganz offen ohne die
anderen europäer
würdest polen in den nächsten wochen
nicht mehr gelingen die für die
versorgung der geflüchteten auch
wirklich menschenwürdig sicherzustellen
und in der folge wenn es wohl nicht mehr
schaffen wird
dann werden wir es perspektivisch auch
nicht schaffen
wir haben die eu richtlinie in der
umsetzung wir haben einen
unkomplizierten status
der den menschen sehr viel freiheit gibt
das ist auf der einen seite positiv der
in der praktischen organisation ist aber
auch nicht einfach macht weil es eben
keine
entsprechenden verpflichtungen
verpflichtenden zuweisungen gibt wie wir
es beispielsweise bei den asylbewerbern
haben
aber es ist ein guter status beschlossen
worden was aber nicht beschlossen worden
ist das ist die solidarische verteilung
und eigentlich gehört auch dies zudem
humanitären schutz dazu und deswegen
brauchen wir jetzt diese europäische
initiative und verehrter bundeskanzler
ich bin mir sicher dass sie hier auch
wissen wie wichtig diese verantwortung
ist denn das gehört dazu auch unsere
regelsysteme sind bereits über laufen
und ich spreche an dieser stelle nicht
nur für die länder sondern ich spreche
auch für die kommunen in deutschland die
mittlerweile begonnen haben die
turnhallen zu belegen und die selbst zum
teil schon an den kapazitätsgrenzen
angekommen sind wir brauchen einen
gemeinsamen
nationalen kraftakt wenn wir
hunderttausende
versorgen wollen und darum brauchen wir
neben der europäischen hilfe und der
europäischen verständigung dringend auch
eine verständigung zwischen bund ländern
und kommunen
ich würde von seiten der länder und
kommunen den vorschlag machen dass wir
so schnell wie möglich am besten noch an
diesem wochenende zu einem flüchtlings
gipfel zusammenkommen um auch mit den
hilfsorganisationen und allen
entscheidenden playern zu besprechen wie
wir neue plätze generieren können damit
wir wirklich verantwortlich handeln
damit wir auch dauerhaft den menschen
aus der ukraine gerecht werden können
bei der versorgung und damit wir unsere
historische aufgabe hier in deutschland
putins vertreibungs terror dem versuch
uns zu
destabilisieren die antwort geben können
die ein klavier putin nicht kennt
nämlich humanität dankeschön
[Applaus]
auf ihn folgt nun michael roth er ist
der vorsitzende des auswärtigen
ausschusses und mitglied der spd
fraktion
lieber frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie mich mit ihnen
beginnen den kolleginnen und kollegen
von der cdu csu
ja ich stimme ihnen zu es ist zeit für
kritische selbstreflexion
ja es auch zeit für selbstkritik aber
nicht für rechthaberei und billigen
ablenkungsmanöver vom eigenen versagen
wenn sie ihre finger wenn ihre finger
auf diese koalition gerichtet sind dann
weisen sie dutzendfach auf sie zurück
fragen sie doch bitte mal den csu
vorsitzenden und bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten
reden sie mal mit dem sächsischen
sprechen sie im übrigen auch mit der
bundeskanzlerin die diese politik seit
jahren geprägt hat und sprechen sie auch
mal mit ihrem ehemaligen
kanzlerkandidaten laschet liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu csu
ich
habe nach dem fall der mauer den
kriegsdienst verweigert wie im übrigen
viele andere männer auch
und ich hätte mir nach 24 jahren
mitgliedschaft im deutschen bundestag
nicht nur humanitäre hilfe für die
ukraine nicht nur eine großzügige
aufnahme von geflüchteten einzufordern
sondern auch waffen
schaffen damit sich dieses land was von
einem brutalen aggressor angegriffen
wurde selbst verteidigen kann dafür
stehe ich ein und dafür tragen wir
gemeinsam die verantwortung und wir
müssen überlegen wie wir diese ukraine
die um ihr überleben kämpft noch weiter
und besser unterstützen können denn ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher
nur eine wehrhafte ukraine kann putin
überhaupt zu ernsthaften verhandlungen
über einen waffenstillstand bewegen
putin will die ganze ukraine und nur aus
einer position der stärke heraus hat die
ukraine eine chance diesen gewalttätigen
prozess der ausschließlich von putin
ausgeht zu überleben liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
die ukraine hat um eine eu perspektive
gebeten
ich unterstütze dies
aus nachbarinnen und nachbarn müssen
mitbewohnerinnen und mitbewohnern des
hauses europäische union werden
ich warne aber vor einer symbolpolitik
dieses angebot muss ehrlich und muss
klar sein wir müssen aus den fehlern
lernen die wir gegenüber dem westlichen
balkan gemacht haben wo die das kosovo
heute noch auf die visaliberalisierung
wartet wohnort mazedonien und albanien
heute noch darauf warten dass endlich
die beitrittsverhandlungen aufgenommen
werden weil bulgarien nach wie vor
blockiert
ich hoffe dass es uns gelingt auch neue
kreative formen der zusammenarbeit zu
finden beispielsweise als vorstufe zu
einer voll mit schafft mitgliedschaft
eine junior mitgliedschaft damit diese
menschen die sich nach unseren
europäischen werten sehnen spüren dass
wir sie nicht alleine lassen weil sie
gehören zu uns das ist eine bürgerinnen
und bürger bewegung die es ja schon seit
vielen jahren gibt und ich finde dass
jetzt die zeit ist ihnen zu sagen unsere
türen sind geöffnet sie bleiben geöffnet
aber es ist ein langer und schwieriger
weg liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich will darüber hinaus auch auf einen
anderen punkt zu sprechen kommen der
mich ein wenig stört
es wird nicht nur in deutschland sondern
überall in europa darüber spekuliert wie
könnte denn ein möglicher kompromiss
aussehen der für die ukraine
annahmefähig sein
was ich vermisse ist die frage wie
könnte denn eigentlich ein kompromiss
für russland aussehen was wussten
eigentlich russland tun damit es zu
einer friedlichen lösung im östlichen
europa kommt und ich kann nur vor
spekulationen baten unsere ukrainischen
freundinnen und freunde wissen selbst am
besten was in dieser schwierigen
situation zu tun ist sie brauchen einer
öffentlichen ratschläge von
politikerinnen und politikern aus
brüssel aus berlin oder aus anderen
europäischen hauptstädten und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die ukraine ist
kein brot von dem ein machthungriger
diktator einfach mal ein partikel
scheiben abschneiden kann so
funktioniert das nicht liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und wenn die ukraine verliert dann haben
auch wir verloren und wenn die ukraine
überlebt dann gewinnen auch unsere werte
dann gewinnen freiheit und
menschenrechte und demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit gegen autoritär
ismus der zum schlimmsten mittel und zur
schlimmsten geisel greift nämlich dem
krieg und das müssen wir gemeinsam
abwenden und deswegen wäre bei allem
notwendigen streit auch ein zeichen der
zusammenarbeit und des zusammenhalts in
diesen schwierigen zeiten nicht nur für
die europäische union sondern vielleicht
auch für diesen deutschen bundestag ganz
hilfreich vielen dank
roth war das kommt hier im
fernsehprogramm verlassen wir den
bundestag online können sie diese
aktuelle stunde auf phoenix de und auf
unserem youtube kanal allerdings weiter
verfolgen und auch die folgende debatte
zu einem neuen nationalen gedenktag aber
wie gesagt sie im fernsehprogramm geht
es jetzt weiter mit meiner kollegin
mayer weber und der tag
tausende tote ukraine
tausende tote
soldaten auf beiden seiten
zehntausende verwundete
hunderttausende flüchtlinge
und 23 monate 3 wochen und verteidigung
die ukraine tapfer
ihre heimat vor fremdherrschaft
von tyrannei
vor unfreiheit und vor unterdrückung
und ich kann nur sagen wenn man das
betrachtet wenn man die bilder sieht
da stockt einem der atem und ich habe
größten respekt und größte bewunderung
für diese tapferkeit und für den mut in
die ukraine tag für tag tatsächlich ob
frauen und kinder ob die männer ob die
alten alle an den tag legen höchsten
respekt
und deswegen ist es natürlich wichtig
dass wir alles unternehmen was wir
können was sinn macht um dieses grauen
zu beenden um für die ukraine die dinge
zu tun um sie wirklich tatkräftig
unterstützen zu können und
deswegen finde ich es tatsächlich
unerträglich der kollege brand hat das
schon gemacht wenn ein mitglied der
regierung oder ein parlamentarischer
staatssekretär in dieser situation
wo ein botschafter seines landes der
täglich diese nachrichten nicht nur von
seinen landsleuten sondern vermutlich
auch von seiner eigenen familie hört und
fleht in deutschland und zwar nicht erst
seit drei wochen sondern seit monaten
für die mehr unterstützung für die
ukraine wenn man dem per twitter hier so
einfach abkanzelt und sagte er es
unerträglich und er sollte sich so
ungefähr am besten schleichen der der
unerträglich an der stelle war björn
barth heute und erklärt wirklich
entlasten sehr geehrte damen und herren
wir haben hier
wir haben hier drei minister
bundesministerinnen gehört und ich bin
sehr dankbar dass die bundesregierung
diese aktuelle stunde
so angelegt hat dass wir tatsächlich was
von der bundesregierung auch hören aber
wir haben auch sehr drei
unterschiedliche beiträge von
bundesministerin gehört und liebe frau
bundesministerin schulze ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen also ihre rede hätte zum
größten teil besser in die nächste woche
gehört in die haushaltswoche zur
allgemeinen beschreibung ihres
themenfeld aber sie war inhaltlich eine
absolute themaverfehlung am heutigen tag
uns mit der überschrift aktuelle stunde
zur aktuellen lage der ukraine
und frau bundesministerin feser weser
entschuldigung
also das was sie hier abgeliefert haben
war ein vortrag zu nach dem motto alles
ist in butter beim thema flüchtlings
unterstützung in deutschland da muss ich
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen ich weiß nicht
wo sie sich so aufhalten aber nichts ist
in butter aktuell mit flüchtlings
unterstützung in deutschland und vor
allem nicht was die vorbereitung auf das
angeht was in den nächsten wochen und
monaten tatsächlich auf uns zukommt und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass der kollege
aus nordrhein westfalen darauf
hingewiesen hat gesagt hat wir brauchen
einen flüchtlings gipfel diese
ankündigung hätte ich von ihnen erwartet
heute in dieser debatte
oder auch mal eine auskunft wer den
tatsächlich die kosten beispielsweise
übernehmen wird der freistaat bayern hat
heute angekündigt im kabinett eine
milliarde euro zur unterstützung der
kommunen wir wissen doch alle in unseren
wahlkreisen dass die bürgermeister dass
die landräte schon jetzt alles
unternehmen um kapazitäten zu schaffen
aber natürlich die bange frage im raum
steht wer bezahlt denn das alles und
deswegen erwarten wir uns auch von von
an dieser stelle eine klare ansage der
bundesregierung und dann liebe frau
bundesministerin berbalk ich habe es
heute im ausschuss gesagt und ich möchte
das weil der ausschuss der
verteidigungsausschuss ja nicht
öffentlich ist auch hier sagen ich habe
muss wirklich sagen kompliment sie sind
im grunde die einzige sichtbare die
konsequent in dieser krise tatsächlich
das tut was sie kann und dafür ein
herzliches dankeschön aber
und das soll das gar nicht schmälern das
soll das gar nicht schmälern aber wenn
sie heute hier ankündigen was wir
absolut begrüßen dass noch mehr getan
wird bei der frage militärische
befähigung der ukraine dann frage ich
mich warum ich dazu noch nichts und
verteidigungsausschuss gehört habe von
der bundesregierung und warum meine
kolleginnen in den anderen ausschüssen
wir haben heute mittwoch heute haben die
ausschüsse getagt wir dazu noch nichts
gehört haben ich sage jetzt mal wir
unterstützen das selbstverständlich aber
wir würden gerne wissen was da genau auf
den weg gebracht wird was das kostet und
was tatsächlich auch die ukraine wollte
ob das tatsächlich auch entsprechend
hilft und deswegen bitten wir hier um
noch mehr auskunft
insgesamt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
glaube ich mit blick brauche nur heute
auf den pressespiegel aus meinem
wahlkreis schauen alles was hier mit
neon orange unterstrichen es sind alles
überschritten zum thema ukraine alles
überschriften zum thema b die
zivilgesellschaft in deutschland auch
helfen will von den pfadfindern die
sammeln von denen die tagtäglichen linie
an die ukrainische grenze fahren ich
habe mir davon selber einen überblick
verschaffen können
ich bin kommen gleich zum ende um die
flüchtlinge abzuholen um güter dorthin
zu bringen ein herzliches dankeschön und
vergelt's gott an alle diejenigen die
sich da entsprechend auch reinhängen und
helfen und in diesem sinne hoffe ich
dass die kollegen bald ein besseres eine
bessere zukunft gibt
florian hahn dass der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
unions religion für die spd-fraktion
spricht jetzt der innenpolitische
sprecher sebastian hartmann
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
21 tage nach dem begriff nach dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf die
ukraine
unermessliches leid vertriebene tote
verletzte jeden tag mehr jede stunde
mehr
dieses unermessliche leid braucht einen
appell an den anfang herr präsident
putin stoppen sie diesen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff sie sind es
die den befehl geben können das leid
jetzt in dieser sekunde zu stoppen meine
damen und herren ich
möchte an diesen appell an schließen
dass wir im vergleich zu anderen und wir
sind in einer zeitenwende situation ein
europäisches aufeinander zugehen haben
ein akt europäischer solidarität
angesichts dieser katastrophe und sie
frau innenministerin phaser haben gleich
am anfang ihrer amtszeit deutlich
gemacht dass sie den begriff der
migration anders interpretieren als
mancher ihrer amtsvorgänger sie sind in
europa auf ihre innenministerin und
innenminister kollegen zugegangen und
haben gesagt wir müssen diese aufgabe
europäisch anpacken und wenige tage
nachdem diese ersten erfolge spürbar
waren waren wir gefordert als es zum
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf die
ukraine kam und wir haben erlebt dass
wir den mechanismus über den temporären
schutz für mehr als drei millionen
menschen die jetzt schon geflohen sind
aktivieren mussten und der dank gilt
wirklich auch der polnischen regierung
und der zivilbevölkerung die
unermessliches leistet über 1,8
millionen menschen jetzt schon in polen
allein um ein beispiel genommen einfach
hilfe leisten liebe kolleginnen
lassen sie nicht aber auch einen punkt
für unsere debatte noch einmal deutlich
machen wenn wir jetzt in dieser
situation uns einmal vor augen führen
welcher vorwurf im raum gewendet dann
ist doch die frage an sie von der
opposition ob wir gemeinsam dieser
aufgabe gerecht werden die sich
insgesamt opposition und regierung
stellt weniger als 100 tage nach
übernahme der regierungsverantwortung
ist es eine vorwurfs arie und sie haben
nicht ein einziges mal gefragt welches
gesetz sie auf den weg gebracht hat sie
haben 16 jahre lang verantwortung in
diesem land getragen es war die union
die in diesem land es war die union in
diesem land in die in diesem land auf
der einen seite mal gesagt hat im august
2015 wir schaffen das und es war ein
bayerischer ministerpräsident der wenige
wochen danach das ganze um getreten hat
indem er sagte das ist die herrschaft
des unrechts und das war der beitrag der
union zu fragen der migration in
deutschland und in europa und an dieser
stelle die wir kolleginnen und kollegen
glaube ich ist es keinem der
ehrenamtlichen helferinnen und helfer
gerecht in diesem land diese debatte
noch einmal in dieser form zu
wiederholen lassen sie uns gemeinsam
zeigen wir haben gelernt dass es eine
europäische antwort braucht und dass wir
in deutschland unseren teil zur lösung
dieser humanitären katastrophe in europa
beitragen werden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und wir tun das das technische hilfswerk
die hilfslieferungen aber auch die
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine die
tatsächlich in diesen stunden darum
ringen dass es nicht noch zu einer
größeren katastrophe kommt wir haben
aber auch etwas getan in diesem haus und
das sollten sie liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger die diese debatte verfolgen
auch wissen wir sind auf die opposition
zugegangen und haben ob leute und
sprecherinnen und sprecher der
oppositionsfraktionen dazu eingeladen
gemeinsam darüber informiert zu werden
teilweise tageweise immer wieder aktuell
um die lage und das haben wir
insbesondere im innenbereich gemacht
weil wir jetzt die verantwortung
übernehmen werden flüchtlinge schnell
und unkompliziert unterzubringen eine
lehre aus dem jahr 2015 und 2016 ist
auch dass wir uns die chance geben
müssen zur zweitbesten nur so nicht jede
lösung ist in dieser situation perfekt
aber sie hilft konkret menschen die
unermessliches leid erlebt habe und wir
sind dazu übergegangen zunächst einmal
10.000 menschen zu begrüßen und zu
verteilen in ehrenamtlichen hilfen aber
danach auch zu erkennen wir müssen jetzt
handeln wir gehen zur registratur auch
sofort über wir haben hunderttausende
von menschen nun in unserem land und wir
verteilen sie auf die länder nachdem das
zur ufa fahren nicht mehr gereicht hat
und nicht mehr ausreichend plätze zur
verfügung schließe mich ausdrücklich
ihnen herr vize-ministerpräsident stammt
an es ist ein nationaler kraftakt von
bund ländern und kommunen
ich würde auch der festen auffassung
dass im vergleich zu 2015 will nicht
eine salami scheiben weise lösung
brauchen sondern wir müssen deutlich
sagen es wird auch mit dem tag des
waffenstillstandes viele ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer geben in diesem land
bleiben die in anderen direkten anrainer
staaten bleiben es wird viele
investitionen bedürfen wir dürfen die
kommunen nicht noch einmal alleine
lassen sondern wir müssen dieses geld in
die hand nehmen das ist das geringste
was wir tun können und jeder der hier in
diesem land ist hat einen anspruch
darauf dass wir diese krise menschens
möglich lösen es ist eine humanitäre
katastrophe und ich wieder den hole den
appell herr präsident putin stoppen
sieht diesen angriffskrieg sie sind
derjenige der den befehl geben kann
stoppen sie diesen angriffskrieg und es
wird auch nichts wenn in dieser stunde
der opposition und regierung irgend ein
historischer so unternommen wird ein
versagen des westens zu konstruieren
nichts rechtfertigt an
völkerrechtswidrigen handlungen und
kinderfrauen menschen krankenhäuser
schulen das passiert in dieser stunde in
der ukraine vielen dank
sebastian hartmann war das der
innenpolitische sprecher der
spd und willkommen damit zum letzten
redner in dieser aktuellen stunde das
ist jörg nürnberger er sitzt für die
sozialdemokratinnen ausschuss für die
angelegenheiten der europäischen union
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
jeden tag sind wir wieder und wieder die
unerträglichen bilder von einem
schrecklichen krieg bilder von einem
angriffskrieg mitten in europa dem
angriff krieg russlands auf die ukraine
die dadurch verursachte lage in der
ukraine ist dramatisch und bestürzt uns
zu tief
europa und deutschland unterstützen die
ukraine deshalb in dieser lage zivil und
militärisch und der hinweis herr hahn
sei gestattet es ist ein gebot
militärischer und politischer vernunft
keine details über waffenlieferungen
öffentlich bekannt zu geben das würde
unsere eigenen soldaten gefährden die
diese waffen liefern
deutschland verhält sich solidarisch und
das entspricht auch unserer
verantwortung in europa wir müssen uns
aber gleichzeitig fragen welche
auswirkungen hat dieser brutale und
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf unsere
westliche staatengemeinschaft
der westen ist geeignet denn je die nato
und die europäische union stehen eng
zusammen und die eu hat in kürzester
zeit vier sanktionspaket von bisher
nicht dagewesenem ausmass verabschiedet
gleichzeitig ist es unsere aufgabe und
im interesse aller westlichen staaten
dafür zu sorgen dass aus dem krieg in
der ukraine kein flächenbrand in ganz
europa wird deshalb kann man auch
manchen sehr verständlichen forderungen
der ukraine nicht wirklich entsprechen
wie zum beispiel der flugverbotszone bei
uns das in diese kriegssituation
einbinden würde
angesichts des krieges in russland gegen
die ukraine führt hat sich die
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitische
lage auch in der nato mitgliedsstaaten
und in deutschland dramatisch verändert
die aggression russlands bedroht die
friedensordnung in ganz europa wir
stehen vor bisher unbekannten
herausforderungen die auch und es geht
mir hier vielleicht die anderen nicht um
die
schuldzuweisung sondern nur um die
objektive feststellung dass diese
herausforderung die versäumnisse der
verteidigungspolitik der vergangenen
jahre offenbaren das gilt besonders mit
blick auf die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
die notwendigkeit mehr in unsere
sicherheit und damit auch in
militärische sicherheit zu investieren
ist nicht mehr von anzuweisen wir müssen
uns noch stärker auf die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
und das insbesondere auch im hinblick
auf unsere östlichen nato partner
fokussieren und zwar nicht nur wegen der
aktuellen lage sondern auch langfristig
die nato aussen flanke wird bereits
heute durch deutsche soldatinnen und
soldaten in litauen und in allernächster
zukunft in der slowakei gestärkt in
rumänien haben wir sechs eurofighter
stationiert in der ostsee und im
mittelmeer stärken marineeinheiten die
nato nord und süd flanken parallel zum
aktuellen engagement der bundeswehr test
nun wichtige und lange überfällige
investitionen voranzubringen ich bin
daher froh dass bundeskanzler stolz
erklärt hat dass wir dieses
sondervermögen einführen werden und dass
zum anderen auch die erhöhung des
verteilt der verteidigungsausgaben auf
zwei prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukt
erreicht werden wird wir senden dann
nämlich ein wichtiges egal erstens an
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten der
bundeswehr
wir kümmern uns endlich um eure
ausrüstung
zweitens an unsere bündnispartner in der
eu und der nato wir stehen zusammen
drittens an die industrie wir sorgen für
langfristige planungssicherheit und
viertens vor allen dingen auch an
wladimir putin wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern
mit diesem sondervermögen sind wir
erstmals in der lage längerfristige
projekte ohne jährliche jeweils
wiederkehrenden erneuert erneute
haushaltsberatungen abzuwickeln
unser ziel ist jetzt also eine
bundeswehr die im vollen umfang
einsatzfähiges eine bundeswehr die damit
auch ihre kernaufgaben der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung vollständig erfüllen
kann und das mit bestmögliche ausrüstung
dazu hat unsere verteidigungsministerin
christine lambrecht bereits einen plan
vorgelegt wie diese ziele erreicht
werden können es soll künftig keine
militärischen luftschlösser mehr geben
sondern es sollen auch bewährte markt
verfügbare produkte und systeme gesetzt
werden und auch bestehende lösungen
aufgebaut werden das beschaffungswesen
soll modernisiert werden wo muss auch
darüber nachdenken in dieser
krisensituation den artikel 346 der eu
von dem nach ausnahmeregelungen von den
vergaben rechten möglich sind anzuwenden
das sondervermögen wird die
beschaffungsvorhaben auch beschleunigen
können und hier hat die bundesministerin
auch angekündigt dass immer stets mit
dem bundestag abzustimmen die 25
millionen vorlagen werden erhalten
bleiben
unsere bevölkerung steht hinter diesen
plänen 74 prozent der menschen in
deutschland stimmen dem zu und insofern
ist auch die koalition bereit diese
verantwortung zu übernehmen wir wollen
aber hier vor allen dingen darüber
diskutieren wie wir zur rückkehr der
diplomatie und zu einer friedlichen
konfliktlösung kommen es ist unser
vorrangiges ziel
dazu zu bewegen die kampfhandlungen
einzustellen
wladimir putin stellen sind die
kampfhandlungen sofort ein leute mir
putin beenden sie diesen krieg
einmal für die spd
damit wird hier diese aktuelle stunde
beschlossen geschlossen morgen um 9 uhr
wird der präsident der ukraine wohl
diverse lenski hier im bundestag noch
einmal zugeschaltet und wird dann hier
auch sprechen auch im europäischen
parlament hat er sich schon einmal
digital auf zu wort geäußert
und das wird er circa 20